[Music]
well hello dear friends
thank you for joining us for a program
i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where
each of you can send us questions we'll
do the research and insofar as possible
we will try and answer your question if
there is an answer in the bible i'd like
to give you the email address where you
can send us your questions you'll see it
on the screen tv at some tv.org
once again tv at some tv dot org
and we will do everything possible to
answer your questions satisfactorily i
have with me daniel miranda who is
associate speaker here at secrets
unsealed one of our associate speakers
we're very glad to have him with us his
bible knowledge is
is great
and he's been a real asset to secrets
unsealed and to some tv we're thankful
that he's here thank you daniel for
being here it's my pleasure to be here
with you pastor boy
we want to begin always with the word of
prayer amen we never should open the
word of god without prayer and so i'd
like to ask you to please have a word of
prayer to ask god to bless the program
my pleasure let's pray
heavenly father once again we come
before you we thank you for this program
we thank you for those who are watching
for those who have sent their questions
and as we open your word we ask for the
guidance and the blessing of your holy
spirit we pray all this in the name of
jesus amen amen
okay we have many many questions we have
a big pile of questions i just want to
emphasize that if you don't get the
answer to your question shortly after
you sent it to us
remember that we have a
great big pile of questions
that people have sent us and we answer
them in the order in which we receive
them so be patient tune into the program
each week and undoubtedly at some point
we're going to answer the question that
you sent us so what question do we have
so this question comes comes from daniel
freeman
and the question is what would have what
would happen or what would have happened
if hadn't if adam hadn't eaten of the
forbidden tree
that's a good question it's a good
question it's one of those what if
questions what if questions yes exactly
well um
we could
speculate about it yes but we'll do our
best not just to stick to what
inspiration says
i'd like us to go to the book of hebrews
chapter two the book of hebrews chapter
2 we are going to read verse 7.
here we
here paul is quoting
psalm 8 in regards to the place of
man in creation
and i'm going to read from verse 6
for the context but one testified in a
certain place saying what is man that
you are mindful of him
or the son of man that you take care of
him and here is the key verse
you have made him a little lower than
the angels you have crowned him with
glory and honor and set him over the
works of your hands
now both the king james and the new king
james
have a marginal reference here where it
says another way of translating this
text where it says you have made him a
little lower than the angels it says you
have made him
for a little while
lower than the angels
now that indicates
that
man was not
supposed to be always
lower than the angels
but before the promotion comes the test
and the test i believe
was to test his obedience his loyalty
and if he had passed the test
then
he would have been promoted and all not
only adam and eve but all the human race
to fill the vacant places in heaven that
satan and his angels left
empty
and i have a quote here from the story
of redemption
um
and this is page 19
paragraph two
the father consulted his son in regard
to at once carrying out their purpose to
make man to inhabit the earth he would
place man upon probation to test his
loyalty before he could be rendered
eternally secure
if he endured the test therewith god saw
fit to prove him he should eventually be
equal with the angels
he was to have the favor of god and he
was to converse with angels and they
with him
he did not see fit to place them beyond
the power of disobedience
yeah and you know there's bible backing
for what ellen white has to say there uh
you know jesus himself said to the
sadducees
that in the resurrection we will not
marry or be given in marriage but will
be like the angels sons of god
so ellen white is not making a comment
that is already not contained in
scripture exactly
i think the insinuation of this question
is is deeper than what appears on the
surface i think that this person is
insinuating is
what would have happened if adam had not
eaten the forbidden fruit what would
have happened to eve
i think that you know maybe i'm i'm
adding to the thoughts of the person who
asked the question because the question
didn't end uh it was cut
it was cut right so so
do we know what would have happened to
uh eve if adam hadn't sinned because
adam was the father and representative
of the race in other words he was the
one that got held accountable
for sin and that's why jesus is the
second adam he's not the second eve
so even though eve sinned first adam was
held accountable
so what would i you know hypotheticals
we love to deal with hypotheticals but
what would have happened if adam had not
listened to the voice of his wife uh
what would have happened to her
well i don't have a dust says the lord
for this so what i'm going to say is
just a speculation and don't take our
word as the final word i mean
the bible doesn't hasn't revealed that
to us at least as far as we know
but
i always
this is an answer i give to myself god
could have just simply
just
punish eve and give him a new wife
that would be the easiest the easier way
but still this is speculation or somehow
he could have redeemed eve or he could
have been dave yeah
and
i don't know how he would have done that
you know whether the whole plan of
salvation would have had to have been
instituted uh you know jesus coming down
taking human flesh and so on but you'll
have to ask that question of jesus
when we get to the kingdom
and hopefully we'll be able to see i
would look forward to seeing eve and not
only adam up there amen
okay so what's our next question
okay our next question
uh comes
from brother arthur
i don't think i can pronounce the last
name
scizak
zim zack or zimzak yes
so his question is in regards to tithe
and the use of tithe and lng white
he says hi not sure if
it was
a lost q but he's still waiting for his
answer so this is the answer to his
question
he says i have read this from ellen g
white he sends us a link and we have
here the letter
that he included in his email it is a
letter that ellen white wrote to elder
watson in june 22nd january january
actually 22nd 1905
and it's in regards to the use of the
tithe
okay
his question is i'm wondering if she's
writing here about the lord's tithe
or is this another tithe
unrelated to the belonging to the lord
okay so what kind of tithe is sister
white talking about here
now
this is a short letter
uh we are not going to read the entire
letter but basically what ellen white
here is saying he's warning elder watson
against making public some things that
she was doing privately in regards to
giving her tithe to
some
neglected ministers in the south that
were preaching
the gospel
and she says that no man should give
notorious notoriety to the fact that in
special cases the tithe is used
in that way she also mentioned some
people that didn't trust the
denomination
and would send her ties
to appropriate it in the best way of her
ability and she would say that she would
appropriate it she would give them a
receipt
but she makes clear that this shouldn't
be
the rule
but circumstances and i quote
circumstances alter cases close quote
so this is basically
the gist of the letter
um
so my our dear brother arthur wants to
know what kind of tithe if this is
referring to the
ties that we know
the the ten percent yes or if this is
another type maybe the second tithe or
an offering
well i think it's pretty clear that it's
dealing with the time exactly with the
ten percent that everyone is expected to
return to the lord at the risk of being
a thief or being dishonest
there are several interesting things
about this letter that
ellen white wrote on january 22 1905 to
elder watson
and
one is that ellen white saw certain she
says white and colored ministers who are
being neglected correct and therefore
she says i took some of the tithe and i
used the tithe to to help those workers
then also
she mentions that some people sent their
tithe to her
for her to help others
who were in need
and
and then the interesting thing is
this
in the letter towards the end of the
letter some cases have been kept before
me for years and i have supplies there
supplied their needs from the tithe as
god has instructed me to do and if any
person shall say to me sister white will
you appropriate my tithe where you know
it is most needed i shall say yes so she
actually accepted tithe from other
individuals who
told ill hawaii to use it where she saw
there was a need
we need to realize that ellen white was
a prophet
who had direct communication from god
and therefore
she probably would not be in the same
category as us right saying you know the
lord has instructed me to give the tithe
to this certain individual over here
you know ellen white as the leader and
the prophet of the seventh adventist
church received supernatural
communications from god as to where the
neglect was and she was instructed to
use the tithe and she does mention also
here
that she's not withholding it
withholding it from the lord's treasury
so in other words she's not keeping it
for herself right she's not embezzling
the tithe she's actually using the tithe
for what it's it should be used which is
remunerating workers who are needy and
she gives receipts as a proof yeah she's
not keeping it for her yeah
so anyway uh you know the person who
wrote this question
uh actually
put here i'm not sure if my question was
lost
in line but i have never seen an answer
so this question must have been asked
quite a long time time ago and hopefully
the person who asked the question is uh
actually watching
because this is a very important
question that comes up quite frequently
yeah
okay what is the next question
next question comes from danny satyawati
uh dear pastors
kindly please advise about country
living very good question country living
get lots of questions about that
do we as seventh-day adventists should
leave our job and go for a country
living
experience in these end times
as written in matthew 24
15 and 16.
therefore when you see the abomination
of desolation spoken off by daniel the
prophet standing in the holy in the holy
place whoever reads let him understand
then let those who are in judea flee to
the mountains
thank you for the answer pastor
danny
well basically
ellen white wrote that it's always
better to live in the country yes
whether we're living in the end times or
not
it's best to live in the country where
you have fresh air you're sounded
surrounded by god's nature where you
don't have the evil influences of
society upon you so
since the late 1800s ellen white was
instructed get out of the cities get all
the cities even many other institutions
this is the reason why secrets unsealed
has made the decision
that we are going to move to a country
location
we actually purchased
435 acres about 40 minutes from here
to relocate the ministry it's going to
take several years probably but
the idea is to move the ministry to a
country location
where
you know where we can serve the lord in
the midst of nature
and um and where we can have a good
source of water and just carry on our
work in harmony with what the spirit of
prophecy tells us amen um
and so it's always good
to have country living but the specific
question is relating to matthew 24
verses 15 and 16
where it speaks about when you see the
abomination of desolation flee so so
what would be god's specific special
counsel
in that time frame
well the texts we need to see in the
context of matthew 24 and we have
already spoken about this in previous
programs
that and pastor bohr has presented it
that matthew 24 is in sequential order
so
this
um
we know that here the abomination of
desolation is referring to the sunday
law okay and so it is
particularly special
uh contextually speaking here at that
time when there will be the last time
and the last opportunity for god's
people to flee
to
the mountains i'm i mean this is
different from leaving the leaving the
cities and going to the country because
before the sunday low you can be
provisioned you can build your house you
can plan your trees but here it's just
fleeing no time for that
just fleeing because of the crisis that
will fall upon the cities during that
time
this is the last opportunity this is the
last opportunity to leave the cities
but it's better to leave before it's
better to leave because it'll be much
more difficult at that time i think
there's a quotation that that you might
want to read there
from volume five of the testimonies um
volume five of the testimonies this is
uh
400 what was the page that you had i
think it's 464
464.
all right
it says it is no time now for god's
people to be fixing their affections or
laying up their treasure in the world
the time is not far distant
when like the early disciples
we shall be forced to seek a refuge in
desolate and solitary places
as the siege of jerusalem by the roman
armies was the signal for flight to the
judean christians so the assumption of
power on the part of our nation in the
decree enforcing the papal sabbath will
be a warning to us
it will then be time to leave the large
cities preparatory to leaving the
smaller ones for retired homes in
secluded places among the mountains
so that's
and hopefully
you'll have the homes
already there right
homes it says homes in the secluded
exclusion of the mountains
so the last opportunity to leave the
cities
is when the sunday law comes
but it's so much better
to make preparations before that correct
now what what um
provisions does ellen white
tell us we're supposed to make if we're
going to move to the country i mean what
what specific
details does she give us about country
living
well she gives several reasons why we
should live we should live in the
country first of all for character
building it's better
country setting is better to
grow in christ have better communion
with god and nature our spirituality
will be improved greatly
when we live in the country
second for
uh those families who have children so
for them there should be plenty of land
garden
for the kids and also the members of the
family to work
and learn some budget lessons from the
garden
she advises that we should plant
fruit trees that they take longer in
advance so that
when the crisis comes we can have some
some food
to eat
for health reasons of course
we she also makes uh
councils to find a place where we can
find water
that's an important provision the
provision of water and if there is a
house
there that's good if there is another
house then we can build a house but
those are basically the the things that
she mentions she also mentions that we
should not be so far away from the city
that we can't witness to the city and
that's another reason that i was
escaping my mind to evangelize
because we we have to be balanced we
don't want to be hermits
in the country but uh we need like jesus
he would spend time in the mountains
praying but he would also serve in the
valleys right so we need to have that
balance we are in the country not too
far from the country so that we can warn
the cities evangelize the cities
so basically the answer to this question
is
country living was always the best
and ask the lord ellen white explains
that we're supposed to ask the lord
for wisdom amen to open doors
to where we can move and when we can
move to the country
and god is going to show us he says that
if we have
a lot of funds
accumulated we should not hoard those in
fact she saw in the in the time of
trouble that many
lamented that they had all of these
resources all of this money they had
and at this point they're not able even
to sell the property that they had and
they said you know the work was
languishing it had great needs and
instead of investing the money in the
kingdom we kept it to ourselves and now
it has no value
and the title of the chapter is our duty
and view of the time of trouble in the
book already writing is the first part
of the book early writings yes
all right so i hope that that answer is
helpful to
the person who asked the question
you know people are sending us questions
whose names are very difficult to
pronounce i've been noticing
uh the the last we probably are
massacring some of these last names
uh set yowari set yawari uh danny set
yawari
so anyway i hope that i didn't massacre
your name
okay now uh we have another question
and
i'll formulate the question and
hopefully you can help us with the
answer this is from natalie vega finally
a word that i can pronounce
the pastor of my church says that the
church manual does not say to take
disciplinary action against a church
member who married a non-believer
it bothers me because the bible says be
not unequally yoked together with
unbelievers for what fellowship hath
righteousness with unrighteousness
who do i follow the bible or the church
manual
well the the
the question about
unequally old couples it's
it's very sensitive and and we should
not use the same rule for all couples
because some
for example the bible says in first
corinthians chapter seven
and let's go there
there is provision in the bible for some
couples
who's one of the
spouses is an unbeliever
and actually policy here says that they
should not separate unless the
unbeliever wants to leave
it says here in 1st corinthians chapter
and we're going to begin with
verse
and a woman who has a husband who does
not believe
if he is willing to live with her let
her not divorce him
for the unbelieving husband is
sanctified by the wife and the
unbelieving wife is sanctified by the
husband otherwise your children would be
unclean but now they are holy but the
other if the unbeliever departs let him
depart
a
brother or a sister is not under bondage
in such cases
but god has called us to peace
for how do you know o wife whether you
will save your husband or how do you
know o husband
whether you will save your wife
now
we don't know specifically from the
passage the passage the passage doesn't
tell us whether
they were unequally yoked after having
light
or before they had light
i mean before they had like both of them
were unbelievers right but uh it is
possible that later one of the spouses
believed
and they were not forced right to
divorce
so this is one particular case
now it is true that the bible
warns against
being unequally yoked
but should a person be
disfellowshipped
or disciplined actually
if
that person marries another person who
is an unbeliever in the church today
you know i think that uh this question
probably i'm not a mind reader but the
person who asked the question
the idea is probably that an individual
who is a seventh-day adventist
marriage marries
someone who is not a seventh-day
adventist yes i think that's what the
question is i think that's the gist of
the question it's not that later on you
know uh one of them is converted to the
faith and the other isn't i think that
this an individual in the church
purposely
fell in love with somebody who was not a
member of the church and uh decided to
get married
and
you know ellen white states that
being on unequally yoke with an
unbeliever
is not only not marrying someone who
is an atheist
but marrying someone who is not of our
faith right
so in other words seventh-day adventists
could marry uh lutheran or methodist
and that would still be yoked together
with an unbeliever and my counsel to
young people is always
even though the person seems you know
like the right person they're nice
they're kind
if they're not of the same faith
follow what god says you can never go
wrong
by obeying god amen follow what god says
and not your feelings and your emotions
because you know
young people unfortunately many many
times
love
goes directly to the heart without going
through the brain first
see the brain has to be the filter amen
uh to to look at you know whether this
is in harmony with god's will
and it is not in harmony with god's will
that we that we get married with someone
who is not of the same faith amen um
you know sometimes it works out
for example my wife has a sister no emma
her husband is ramon
she married him
while he was not an adventist
in fact i don't think he was going to
church anywhere
and you know the she shared the message
with him and the pastor shared the
message with him
and to this day he became a strong
seventh-day adventist amen but but what
i say is that's like playing the lottery
[Laughter]
how many people actually win the lottery
it's a very very small percentage of
people that actually win and that's true
also of a believer marrying an
unbeliever it might be that it works out
in the long run
but it's a high risk so it's better to
obey what god says in his word amen
absolutely all right so by the way i
don't know where the where the church
manual
doesn't say don't take disciplinary
action
who married an unbeliever i haven't read
that in the church manual but
you know it's kind of like ellen white
the biggest book that ellen white wrote
is the one that is called ellen white
says
and so these days it's very common for
pastors and church members to say the
the church manual says but many times
the church manual doesn't say it's just
a way of getting off the hook
so anyway well that's the question the
next question that we have i think we
already answered
it's the one on
if there are 66 books in the bible only
how do you explain jude 1 14
where it speaks about enoch
the seventh from adam so i think we
already answered that one so we won't
take the time uh during this particular
session to answer that question because
people have to look in the ark in the
archives tell us something about the
archives
so you can go to our channel youtube
channel
some tv and you can there click
and
go to the tab that says videos or
playlists and you'll find all our
previous programs from from last year
and the previous year and that way you
can know
what uh episodes have been answered also
in our app download our app and there in
the app you should be able to see the
questions that have been asked the ones
that have been answered in our programs
and i'll give you a title of what uh the
gist of the question so you're able to
scroll quickly and find uh if the
question has been asked and answered
before well time is about up we want to
thank you for joining us today for our
program i'd like to know
and we hope that you will join us next
time meanwhile may the lord bless you
and keep you in his care and we hope to
see you next time blessings
[Music]
you